pendant tant d être beaucoup de
québécois c'est peut-être votre cas vont
prendre la route du soleil où vont se
préparer à partir à la plage d'autres
sont plus aventureux recherche des
destinations peut-être moins connus
moins fréquentées par la majorité des
touristes
quels sont justement les destinations
les plus populaires en 2019 avec nous et
andré desmarais il est le vice président
de l'association canadienne des agences
de voyages bonjour monsieur desmarest
bonjour bonjour alors chaque année il ya
des destinations qui sont peu plus
populaires que d'autres on a beaucoup
entendu parler du portugal plein
d'ennemis qui sont allés là au cours des
derniers mois là cette année 2010 neuf
là où avoir écouté je pense que les gens
sont de plus en plus habitués à voyager
c'est sûr que les élus car et les
croisiens vont demeurer des destinations
privilégiées
mais les gens vont un peu plus loin
maintenant vont vers les destinations
comme les îles seychelles les maldives
la thaïlande vietnam l'asie beaucoup
beaucoup de popularité auprès des médias
en ce moment parce que aussi les
croisiéristes ont développé ces circuits
là aussi alors on sent quand même une
facilité chez les voyageurs de
maintenant aller vers des destinations
qui sont un peu plus exotiques dont
quasi denaisis ces deux destinations ont
dit oui absolument
les gens ont moins peur de faire de
longues longues heures d'avion
maintenant absolument
bon il ya beaucoup de conflits également
dans mon rôle de vue regarder juste aux
nouvelles on parlait tout à l'heure la
dc touristes en egypte qui ont été tuées
avec un guide
où sont ces endroits peut être à éviter
est ce que l'égypte c'est un
c'est très triste pour l'egypte parce
que l'egypte l'industrie touristique est
probablement une des principales
industries de ce pays
alors tout le maghreb a subi des des
arbres par rapport aux monnaies des
actes de terrorisme qui ont complètement
ruminer leur industrie elle sera bâtie
et l'egypte avaient repris énormément de
popularité et ça fait maintenant bien
entendu c'est un phénomène ponctuel
parce que bon on ne croit pas que ça va
être une résurgence et ça va revenir
régulièrement malheureusement pour
l'egypte
c'est sûr que les gens sont apeurés mais
vous voyez on a quand même des tsunami
en indonésie
on a des problèmes en terre en cécile
alors sans que ce soit des voyages exact
c'est important quand même avant de
partir de voir le site du gouvernement
du canada pour surtout pour des
destinations qui sont moins populaires
parce que aujourd'hui le développement
d'énergies touristiques ont amené des
gens aller vivre chez l'habitant
parlant des choses comme ça parce que
c'est plus écologique
mais c'est on veut goûter davantage aux
pays bas actuels alors à cause de ça il
est très important à mon sens de se
renseigner auprès du gouvernement du
canada des destinations auxquelles on
veut on va les suivre la situation de
près si ce sont des hommes un peu plus
instable
on parlait d'asie les relations entre la
chine et le canada se sont un peu plus
tendue depuis un certain temps est ce
que c'est un endroit
évitez moi je ne pense pas que ce soit
un endroit à éviter pour le touriste
alors écoutez c'est sûr que on sait que
la chaîne a des règles d'administration
qui lui sont propres ils font ce qu'ils
veulent mais c'est peut-être plus pour
des gens qui sont en affaires et qui
font des tractations qui peuvent être
sujets à polémique mais pour un touriste
la chine demeure encore un pays dont
l'importance de suivre les informations
l'actualité dans ces pays là également
bon il y en a qui vont vouloir faire des
voyages plus éco touristique ou
humanitaires
d'abord la différence et où on peut
aller pour faire ça mais écoutez nous je
sais qu on a des groupes humanitaires de
médecins qui vont pratiquer en afrique
dans les dispensaires il ya des écoles
aussi qui fondent et des voyages
éducatifs mais en même temps de
bénévolat et comme j'expliquais il ya
des niches même où on revit chez
l'habitant mais en même temps on
participe à du travail local de support
à la communauté parce ça devient des
nouvelles niches comme j'expliquais de
plus en plus les voyageurs sont appelés
maintenant ils ont nous ont pris
l'expérience et vont de plus en plus
touchée des choses exotiques
alors souvent aussi d'aller dans ces
endroits là ça donne une bonne
conscience parce qu'on sait qu'on allait
faire la plonge et par exemple nettoyer
une partie de l'os et justement c'est en
europe qu'il ya des écolos plongée qui
pensent nous reste quelques secondes une
ou deux destinations pour les gens qui
sont un peu plus aventuriers la ben moi
écouter je pense que le vietnam est une
belle destination et écouter ses bras
dessus pendant sénégal
ça fait partie des destinations les îles
maldives seychelles comme j'expliquais
c'est des endroits où c'est très
balnéaire mais c'est quand même un autre
c'est notre société mais ce qui est
toujours important en tout cas c'est
toujours se renseigner auprès du
gouvernement des situations et bien
entendu aussi de vérifier pour les
vaccins ces choses là c'est très
important tout en plusieurs pays
d'afrique
c'est important en effet andré desmarais
merci beaucoup on va souhaiter le bond
de bon voyage
tous les canadiens qui vont à prendre
l'avion pour aller visiter de nouveaux
endroits